I had a lot of trepidation about this
conference and about my speaking I had
even a brief moment of hope that the war
would cancel it because I wasn't sure
what it would be like to talk to a group
of people while robot bombs are falling
on our enemies around the clock I just
couldn't picture that so normally I just
sort of take flight and whatever's on my
mind gets splattered on to your mind but
I don't feel so certain of myself in
this situation I'm not sure that just
taking flight for another a vocation of
the psychedelically aided evolution and
transformation of our species is the way
to go because I think maybe we should or
I should attempt something it's a little
rare for me plane talk plane talk about
what's going on yesterday Bob Wilson got
up and talked about the war and then Tim
cheered him on and put his stamp of
approval on that I thought it was great
and then we broke and somebody cornered
me for an interview and they said what's
with these guys dragging politics into
this thing this is not a political
meeting I was I didn't say anything I
just tried to you know assimilate that
and then last night I thought about it
and I've been thinking about it about
this war about the 60s about Vietnam
about how LSD played a major role in
stopping that war by forcing people to
confront what they were really doing by
empowering people to get together in
large groups and say we
won't stand for it we won't put up with
it and even though the war is now two
weeks old whatever it is for the first
time really last night I got why it
feels so bad to me personally and by
extension I think to all of you aside
from all the horrors of war which you
have had rehearsed for you over the past
two weeks what really is a pisser about
this is that it means for people my age
and older they didn't hear us
we weren't heard when they were bombing
Libya we could just call that an
aberration when they were hunting down
Noriega we could just call that a large
dope bust this is none of those things
this is war and what we said if you can
take the psychedelic and political
struggles of the 1960s and boil it down
into one phrase what did we stand for we
stood for making love not war
[Applause]
and ever since Thomas the Marines were
shoved into the sea at Da Nang and the
CIA was helicoptered off the embassy
roof in Saigon we've been able to hold a
delicate and very tense balance between
the view of the dominator weapon
worshiping old-style macho approach to
things and our own and I think we all
felt I certainly did last August when
they began to move the chess pieces
around that we would not stand for it
that there was a we and that we would
not stand for it
and if you were able to keep your
idealism intact until the congressional
debate when you felt then they represent
us they will stop it after all it's the
opposition party to the administration
it's an anti-war party they will stop it
and they went like sheep to the
slaughter to the slaughter and they
voted for it so now we have no excuse no
no faction was overridden
nobody's rights were trampled on the
path to this debacle we we the people of
the United States by some staggering
percentage approve of this well so
that's to people like myself and Tim
Leary and Bob Wilson and John Lilly and
all the people who aren't here and all
of you that I've grown up with and
worked with this is an abomination we
stand for consciousness expansion do you
know how much you have to have for
brains to wage war its staggers the
imagination
we stood for deconditioning asking
questions resisting Authority today no
questions are being asked
authority is not being resisted oh yes
there are demonstrations against the war
but in a democracy they have what's
called a 5% rule it doesn't matter if
only five percent are involved in it it
doesn't matter what it is so we have
been effectively isolated our names are
have been metaphorically signed to the
bottom line of these documents that
commits us to war how do you feel about
that